wenn georg simon morgens zu seinem kiosk
geht war meist schon mehrere dutzend
menschen auf ihn aber nicht etwa um bier
oder zigaretten zu kaufen sie alle
wollen einen corona schnelltest machen
also das sind die test sich heute
bekommen habe über den rettungsdienst
aus stockstadt am rhein habe zehn
apotheken die mich hier wirklich von
keiner hatte mit tests in frankfurt
simon ist internist kann daher die
schnelltests beziehen und in abstimmung
mit den zuständigen ämtern das
provisorische einpersonen test center
betreiben
auslöser dafür den leerstehenden kiosk
umzurüsten war für den frankfurter
familienvater die zeit in der er selbst
versucht hat schnell einen test zu
machen um in den urlaub fahren zu können
dann habe ich gedacht ich bin für innere
medizin ich bin gerade in elternzeit
habe ich jedoch es kann doch nicht sein
dass in frankfurt kein test verfügbar
ist und dann habe ich ja mittags immer
gut seid jetzt eine elternzeit für knapp
40 euro bietet er ein ergebnis im
schnelldurchlauf fiebermessen abstrich
20 minuten warten dann weiß die
testperson ob sie sich angesteckt hat in
den letzten tagen war dies immerhin bei
jeder achten der fall
tendenz steigend dann wurden es immer
mehr
und mittlerweile bin ich eigentlich an
meiner leistungsgrenze den bock in
charakter der textstelle bild simon
trotzdem beibehalten
dabei sorgt er sich um die menschen die
teils schon zwei stunden vor öffnung des
chaos in der kälte stehen auf seiner
webseite warnt er deshalb dass wegen
lieferengpässen bei corona schnelltests
nur 25 bis 75 tests am tag verfügbar
sind
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaute ich je das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht abonnieren